jeudi comme kelly toute façon ça se fera
un film sont gênées à l'idée ça se fera
donc autant que ce soit olivier marchal
que moi aussi comme lui reste l'équipe
j'adore autant celui qui s'y colle parce
qu'il y aura là comme tu as dit valérie
les côtés onglet côté lumière moi le
seul truc que je j'arrive à me dire
j'essaye de visualiser tu vas apprendre
qui comme acteur pour faire devant
johnny alors je vous le dis tu vois il
soit sur l'art sur la zone fille il se
sur quelqu'un allait qui est il ce soir
gérard depardieu
parce que là c'est maintenant le vrai
défi y basque à risque des les geôliers
qui va remonter sur scène qui va chanter
qui va dégager ça il parle alors il
parle de hyères il parle de rachid
badouri
voici deux choses comme il était de son
projet il se peut qu'il en est un des
deux qui se soit engagé auprès d'olivier
marchal alors que l'autre soit
nécessairement complètement au courant
ça se passe très souvent
deuxièmement on a aussi le droit de pas
aimé le projet moi je sais que j'adore
olivier marchal
mais honnêtement est-ce que j'irai voir
un film sur johnny non alors un nom
facile
il est gros il est trop incarner présent
je vais vous dire un truc nous aussi je
laisse vous faire un aveu et je vous
donne un fou vous savez que je vais je
pense je produit également des films
cinéma là on va produire un documentaire
magnifique sur une dame qui retournent à
l'école à 80 disons c'est c'est
bénéfique et je vous le dis on a en
projet également nous de faire un film
sur johnny qui s'appellerait l'idole
voilà sur la vie de johnny hallyday donc
c'est vrai qu'à plusieurs projets et
nous aussi avec nos modes de production
on a un projet sur le film johnny et on
a trouvé l'acteur qui jouerait eu johnny
jeunes
oui je vous le dit et il lui ressemble
beaucoup
wade c'est un jeune quoi bouder non pas
bouder est ce que vous le dites il lui
ressemble beaucoup
c'est un jeune comique qui monte il
ressemble beaucoup à johnny je vous le
dévoiler dans un instant comique oui
vous voulez dire qu'il est génial comme
benoît magimel
non c'est jérémy qui traînait c'est ce
que ce monsieur comme exactement jérémy
qui est un excellent acteur on va vous
montrer sa photo et on l'a tous chercher
sa photo mais c'est vrai qu'on a un
projet une base en faut 2 il vous fera
un johnny en jeune johny envieux et
alors pour l'instant on va faire que
dieu nous donne
vous conduirez le domaine